today on the matt welsh show the
cowardly governor of arkansas
vetoes a bill that would have banned the
chemical castration of children in the
state the republican party continues to
prove itself utterly useless in the
fight against the radical left
also five headlines including the
insanely lenient plea deal
offered to the two girls who carjacked
and murdered a man in dc
if this is privilege it ain't white male
privilege that's for sure also
another family harassed on a plane
because their young children weren't
masked
and derek chovin's defense gets the
police chief to make a surprising
admission on the stand we'll play that
for you
plus our daily cancellation and much
more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know one of the ugliest marine
mammals uh or rather marine animals i
should say not a mammal is known as the
blob fish
if you saw only a picture of it online
you might imagine that you're looking at
some sort of strange
half melted claymation character but the
blobfish is very real floats along the
sea floor
a slimy droopy gelatinous toothless
bottom feeding invertebrate mass
capable only of eating whatever
microscopic edible material happens to
float in front of it
it also has no muscle and uh in no
defense mechanism
except to slink along in the dark hoping
that the bigger fish don't notice it
this is why i've long believed that the
blobfish should be the republican
party's mascot
republicans certainly are not worthy of
their elephant totem elephants are
noble intelligent strong sturdy
formidable
elected republicans with very rare
exception are
none of those things they are much more
like the blob fish spineless
squishy ridiculous defenseless
slithering along uselessly in the muck
hoping not to be noticed over the last
couple weeks republicans have worked
especially hard to
earn the new mascot that i'm proposing
uh first christie gnome of south dakota
vetoed a bill as we discussed on this
show that
would have banned males from women's
sports the stated reason for the veto
was that the ncaa
would be mad at her if she signed it and
she doesn't want to make the mad that's
only a slight paraphrase if you remember
when we played that audio clip if you
thought that would be the most egregious
cave we've seen from a republican this
spring you were mistaken
caving after all is what republicans do
best perhaps on second thought i should
have suggested a sinkhole as the gop's
emblem
maybe that would be more appropriate
even and that brings us to asa
hutchinson
the republican governor of arkansas
hutchinson ever the
chivalrous gentleman decided to rescue
gnome from having to bear the title as
the party's new biggest wimp
so yesterday the governor announced that
he was vetoing a bill
that would have banned the chemical
castration of children and all other
forms of
quote gender transition therapy for
minors who lack the ability to fully
consent
to such life-altering procedures now i
can see how a conservative who's been
living underground let's say for the
past 15 years
or maybe at the bottom of the sea to
keep the blob fish thing going
might oppose such a bill simply because
it would seem to them to be so
wildly unnecessary i mean surely they
they might protest we
we don't need legislation to stop
doctors from trying to physically turn
boys and the girls
nobody would ever do such a thing we
don't need this bill
you might think that if you have not
been above ground and conscious for the
last 15 years but asa hutchinson
has been above ground and conscious as
far as i know he's been in the
governor's mansion
which might as well be underground in so
many cases but
no he knows that a bill like this is
indeed necessary though it should not be
but it is
this is no mere theoretical or academic
issue many millions of children are
being
being indoctrinated into the left gender
theory doctrines as we speak
they're having gender confusion
purposefully instilled in their minds
a certain sizable portion of them will
eventually be quote transitioned
so this is a real issue and an important
one
there are not many issues that can
reasonably consider be considered more
important as far as i can tell
hutchinson as a sane though spineless
man
knows all of this he vetoed the bill
anyway on the basis that stopping
doctors from doing physically
from dosing physically healthy children
with dangerous hormone blockers is
somehow
government overreach he said here he is
explaining
house bill 1570 would put the state
as the definitive oracle of medical care
overriding parents patients and health
care experts
while in some instances the state must
act to protect
life the state should not presume to
jump
into the middle of every medical human
and ethical issue
this would be and is a vast government
overreach
this this guy he's 70 years old
he's about to be term limited thank god
uh he can't he can't run for
re-election anyway 70 years old he's
getting term limited out of the uh
out of um out of the the position as
governor
what does he have to lose there's
literally nothing to lose you might as
well just sign the bill
yet he can't do it that's how much of a
of a
completely useless coward this person is
even in that position with nothing to
lose he still can't do it
he's terrified he's terrified
of making people mad at him now he says
he worries that the bill would allow the
state to
override parents patients and health
care experts
but the patients in this case are
children we override the decisions of
children all the time
i often have to issue my own parental
vetos squashing my son's plan to
eat nothing but ketchup and bread for
every meal or my daughter's proposal
that she made recently that we capture a
squirrel
and bring it into the house as a pet
okay i had to veto that
kids are famously bad at analyzing the
long-term effects
of their actions or even the short-term
effects it's not their fault they lack
the neurological equipment to think in
those terms
this is why we don't let children get
tattoos or buy guns or buy tobacco
products
they're simply too young to make those
kinds of decisions for themselves
override them yes of course all the time
that's our job as adults
what about the parents and the quote
health care experts
well we'd have no trouble overriding a
parent
who took his 11 year old son into the
tattoo parlor to get a giant picture of
scooby-doo
inked permanently on his forearm we
would not only override such a parent
but they would likely get a visit from
child protective services wouldn't they
it's possible for a parent to be wrong
in the decisions they make for their
child
it's possible for healthcare experts to
be wrong too
this is one of those times indeed
healthcare experts not long ago
would have said that a gender confused
child is either going through a phase or
worse cases suffering from
a mental disorder there would have been
there would have been no discussion of
putting the child on drugs to change his
body
in order to conform it with his
delusions therapy and counseling would
have been the preferred treatment course
not long ago as it turns out we have no
choice
but to use the word wrong in reference
to these healthcare experts they were
either wrong a few years ago
or they're wrong now if you think
they're right
now then you think they were wrong
before
whichever way you go you're calling
healthcare experts wrong god forbid
and that's fine because healthcare
experts can be wrong
and they most certainly are wrong in
this case
and by the way it's not like every
healthcare expert actually agrees with
this anyway
despite what you may may have been told
not every healthcare expert is
lining up to endorse the idea of
drugging children who are
gender-confused
it's just that the ones who don't
endorse it either are too afraid to
speak too loudly in their opposition or
if they do speak up in opposition
they're going to be
well they're going to get exactly the
kind of treatment that asa hutchinson
was afraid of of receiving which is why
he made the decision he made
now hutchinson further explaining his
veto also explained that um
the bill is quote opposed by the leading
arkansas associations
and the leading arkansas associations
what associations ah just the leading
ones
you know the associations all of them
they don't like it
and he says and the concern expressed is
that denying best
medical care to transgender youth can
lead to significant harm to the young
person from suicidal tendencies and
social isolation
to increased drug use okay consider what
is happening here
a republican governor in arkansas
is affirming the idea that chemical
castration may be quote the
best medical care for a boy who's
confused about his gender
again this is a view so radical that
only a few years ago
it wasn't even accepted by the most
fringe people on the left now in the
blink of an eye
elected republicans in the south are
endorsing it
our plunge into madness has hit warp
speed
and the republican party is completely
incapable of doing
anything about it and unwilling and what
is this medical care exactly
well in many cases it means physically
healthy boys taking drugs
that were initially developed to treat
prostate cancer in grown men
okay we're giving cancer drugs to
children
who are physically healthy they're being
dosed with off-label cancer drugs in
order to halt their normal growth in
maturation
and to make their bodies more feminine
these same kinds of drugs by the way are
also used to chemically castrate sex
offenders
so i just want to reiterate that again
we're giving um
drugs to little boys
and and those same kinds of drugs are
used to chemically castrate sex
offenders
now all of this is done based on two
premises right number one
these are the premises one that some
male children are really girls
and some female children are really boys
and number two
that it's possible to turn the male
children into girls by giving them drugs
and vice versa for the female children
both of these premises are wildly false
utterly indefensible these are also not
medical or scientific but philosophical
assertions
they are grounded in the belief that the
self right the self is this
amorphous indeterminate relative
thing according to this philosophical
view we can
make and remake ourselves however we
like because nothing about us is
ingrained or innate except our race
somehow
this this this claim does not become any
more credible just because
doctors or medical experts make it it is
again
not a medical claim it is
a religious dogma and it's absurd on its
face
in reality if a child has gender
dysphoria
um no hormone drug or surgery could ever
be an effective treatment or an ethical
one
the gender dysphoric person feels you
know trapped inside a body that doesn't
match to use the national health
services phrase
this obviously cannot be anything
but a disorder of the mind it should go
without saying that a person cannot
actually have
the wrong body it doesn't make any sense
it's not as if our minds are entirely
separate entities
that are poured inside our bodies like a
liquid into a container
on some sort of apparently mistake prone
cosmic assembly line
it's a very strange form of dualism that
sees the human person this way
i am my body i can know i can no more
have the wrong sex then i can have the
wrong
right knee or the wrong left pinky
finger or wrong
eye color i am who i am biologically
speaking
i cannot be anything other than that
no matter how i might feel about it if i
have trouble accepting my biological
nature then the correct course of
treatment must be one that helps me to
accept it deforming mutilating poisoning
or castrating me
or suppressing my healthy physical
development in any other way would be
precisely
the wrong approach it's exactly like
exactly like giving laxatives
and you know a fun house mirror to an
anorexic
and the anorexic believes she's fat when
really she's not
it would be cruel to quote treat a
person struggling with this
disorder by helping them to better see
themselves
by the light of their delusion
okay if an anorexic person comes up to
you and says i think i'm fat the last
thing you're going to do is say you know
what you're if you identify as fat then
you are
i mean if that's how you feel i'm not
going to tell you that you're wrong if
that's how you identify
let's get you some diet pills
no the point is that the anorexic thinks
she's fat
but she's not the gender dysphoric boy
thinks he's a girl
but he's not the confusion is the issue
not his body
not puberty not his natural biological
functions
they are not sick if anything is sick
it's his mind and that's what should be
treated
although in the case of children most of
the time there's nothing even wrong with
their minds they're just going through a
normal phase
they're confused it's a very natural
thing for a child to be
confused especially when they don't have
any guidance from the adults in their
lives
this is the position of all reasonable
and decent people
um and yes so if you don't hold the
position that i have just described
you are not a reasonable decent person
you are a twisted
perverse evil person
you know if you would in any this this
is this is not a gray area issue okay
there are issues where
reasonable decent people can disagree
respectfully
there are issues like that plenty of
issues this is not one of those issues
if you endorse the idea of chemically
castrating children
you are a disgusting horrible person
that's it
or you're in crazy like those are the
two options
but the problem is that it also requires
some small hint of courage
some small hint of courage to be
reasonable and decent in an unreasonable
and indecent culture
for many republicans such as asia
hutchinson that is simply too high a bar
to get over they will in the end go
along with any evil
affirm any lie countenance any delusion
so that they might live another day
politically and socially
not live to fight another day but simply
to
float another day out of sight out of
mind
hoping that they will be eaten last
let's get now to our five headlines
one of the most important things for
your health and general wellness
and also sanity is to get a good night's
sleep but you really can't
do that when you don't have a good
pillow you've got some
flimsy thing that's just not supporting
your head it's not giving you
you know that it's it's not allowing you
to sleep in the position you want to
sleep in um
you're not going to sleep well and
that's why you need a my pillow
but now you've heard you talk about my
pillow and uh you know you've heard me
say all
the great things about my pillow i use
it myself every single night i cannot
say enough good things about it
but now introducing something almost as
good it's the new my slippers the
slippers took over
two years to develop and they're
designed to wear indoors and outdoors
all day long the my slippers are made
with my pillow foam
and the impact gel to help prevent
fatigue and they're made with a quality
leather suede
i can tell you firsthand i got the my
slippers a few days ago i wear them
around the house all the time i'm a big
slipper fan in general
slipper apologist and these are the best
slippers i've ever had for a limited
time
my pillow is offering 40 off their new
my slippers yes
40 off so i now have the sheets pillows
and slippers for my pillow
uh and like all their the products the
comfort is key you can also get this
what you got to do is go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listener square
and use promo code daily wire you'll
also get deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the giza dream bed
sheets the my pillow mattress topper and
my pillow towel sets or
you can call 800-951-7163 and use promo
code dailywire visit mypillow.com now or
call
800-951-7163
all right where are we starting here so
the daily mail has this
says two girls ages 13 and 15 who were
charged with the murder and carjacking
of a pakistani immigrant killed last
month
while working at his job delivering food
in washington dc
uh have reportedly reached a plea
agreement with prosecutors
now you remember this um
this case talked about it a few days ago
uh
maybe maybe if you didn't watch the show
or you you know you weren't
if you weren't paying attention to
conservative media that day you may not
have heard of it because
the you know the mainstream media was
certainly happy to move on and not talk
much about it but
it's on video these girls they carjacked
this pakistani immigrant mohamed anwar
66 years old
um he was trying to do his job
delivering food for ubereats you know
and they tried to
steal his car they had a taser and he
attempted to stop them from stealing his
car because this is his livelihood he
needs his car
in order to support himself and and his
family
and they drive off with him hanging out
of the car
they flip the car send him hurdling he
dies on the pavement
bleeding and then and then they're
rescued from the car by some
national guardsmen who are standing
there and nobody has any concern for
muhammad anwar who's just
laying there bleeding uh dead or dying
no one even checks on him and the girls
the only thing they're worried about is
their phone
they're like stepping around the dead
man saying i need my phone i need my
phone
so that's the case if you didn't hear
about it well on monday
the teens reportedly reached the plea
deal with prosecutors that would ensure
um that they will not be held past the
age of 21
nor be placed in a prison facility
so they carjacked a man and murdered him
and they're not going to prison
according to this they're not going to
spend a day in prison
and they'll be totally free to go by the
age of 21
which means in uh for the one girl in
the by in six years
if she's getting any sentence at all you
know it's and it's not gonna be prison
it's six years
now you have to ask you know this this
girl
who murdered a man at 15
and uh and cared so little for his life
that the only thing she was worried
about was
her phone afterwards
do you think like six years from now
after spending six years in whatever the
juvenile detention
system or wherever she is going you
think she's gonna be magically a better
person
and less of a danger to society
right now she is a murdering sociopath
who does not value human life at all
so you add six years on top of that
going through the juvenile you know
system um and after she's already been
getting given the message from the court
system that what she did wasn't all that
bad
i mean it was bad but not that bad
you think those factors are going to
make her a better person
less of a danger
you know when this part this person gets
out of jail are you going to feel would
you feel comfortable around her would
you let her babysit your kids
no i don't think so no we we all this is
the way it's gonna we all know how it's
gonna go because it's gone this way a
million times so we all know this story
and the story is um she gets the slap on
the wrist from the court system
they release her uh back after after she
does her
you know pays pays a whatever penalty
whatever symbolic penalty
and she's released back into society and
you know a couple months later a couple
of years later
she will either be dead or she'll have
killed someone or both
and if she's not dead she'll be back
she'll end up back in prison in this
time for you know 10
15 years and then we'll release her
again and we'll do this all over again
while she continues to be nothing but a
danger to
and a strain on society
and all for what
now the other question we have to ask
ourselves is um
if in this case these girls these were
uh two teenage black girls
you know let's just ask ourselves if
this was uh especially in dc
of all places if this was if we had a
video
of a 15 year old white male teenager
carjacking a pakistani immigrant and
killing him and then getting out of the
car and the only thing he's worried
about his phone
is his phone do you think he's going to
get this deal you think that's gonna
happen
especially in dc we all know no that's
not gonna happen
so this is an example of privilege but
it's not white male privilege that's for
sure
and i think you know their race
certainly helps them
in this case but gender is probably
the the most salient factor here
because the fact is that women there are
there's a lot of
ingrained privilege for women in our
culture today
and nowhere is that more apparent than
in the court system
in fact here's an article this i think
is uh relevant here's an article from
mission from the michigan law website
and it says i'm talking about a recent
uh research paper that was done
it says if you're a criminal defendant
it may help a lot to be a woman
at least that's what professor sanja
starr's research on federal criminal
cases suggests
professor star's recent paper quote
estimating gender disparities in federal
criminal cases looks closely at a large
data set of federal cases
and reveals some significant findings
listen to this
after controlling for the arrest offense
criminal history and other prior
characteristics quote
men receive 63 percent longer sentences
on average than women do
and women are twice as likely to avoid
incarceration if convicted
this gender gap the gender gap is about
six times as large as the racial
disparity that professor starr found
in another recent paper now we hear a
lot about the racial disparity in the
court system
um the gender disparity is much more
significant
and we don't hear anything about it now
keep in mind again because
one of the things if ever you bring this
up
and you bring up the fact that women are
much more likely to get a lenient
sentence which is true
the immediate response will be yeah well
women commit less
violent crime and all that no this is
after controlling for
the type of crime uh criminal history
all of that
so you take a man and a woman at least
in federal court
and they're identical
in what they've done in their criminal
history only thing that's different is
their
sex the woman's going to get a lesser
penalty
significantly lesser penalty
so this is the case here this is um
what's happening with these girls i
would call this
it's a couple of levels of privilege
here as they're as they get to
cash in their victim points
which which literally amounts to a get
out of jail free card in this case
or at least get out of prison free
because they're not going to prison
but of all the privilege their female
privilege i think is the most
significant here all right number two a
family
with a two-year-old and a special needs
child was
kicked off temporarily kicked off a
spirit airlines flight
they were eventually let back on
apparently but
that doesn't that doesn't make what
we're about to see here okay
and uh let's let's watch it here
i told you non-compliant
meanwhile both of the both of the adults
are wearing a mask
all we see there is the the toddler
who's by the way totally unbothered so
you gotta like about toddlers she's just
sitting there
enjoying her yogurt completely oblivious
to everything
[Music]
yeah she's eating a yogurt and she's not
not only is she a toddler but she's also
in the process of eating
and so that's why she's getting singled
out
i'm not going to leave until i'm on okay
all right and then and then eventually
they were so
they also have a special needs child who
you can't see in the video right now but
sitting in between the parents there's a
special needs child
uh a little bit older but he you know he
looks like he's i don't know how old he
is but
certainly young he's a young child um
they were eventually kicked off the
flight
forced to to get off the flight and then
they and then they were allowed to get
back on
after going through all of this
rigmarole and the uh
humiliation and all of that they were
eventually let back on
that doesn't make this okay though to
harass a family with young children
and humiliate them like this
only to let them back on it none of that
is okay i mean this is this is evil
behavior
and what i hate the most about it there
are so many things i hate about but
the worst thing and you can it's hard to
hear the audio but you can hear the
flight attendant there saying that hey
this is the policy there's nothing i can
do about it and yeah
i i don't like it either but having
these people
hide behind policy
while they're you know harassing
families who aren't doing anything wrong
insisting that they muzzle their young
children for no reason
no no real medical reason just do it
because it makes everyone else feel
more comfortable allegedly and they hide
behind the policy
well you know policies are not these
uh you know like deities that are
hovering there and and
and can cause you to do things you don't
want to do policies are just
they're nothing unless you have people
to enforce them
a policy can't do anything unless people
enforce it
and so if you are choosing to enforce it
then you can't hide behind that policy
that's a choice that you are making
and meanwhile this is spirit airlines
like if this doesn't convince you to
stop flying spirit then i don't know
what will
because on top of this on top of them
harassing young families with young
children
they're also just one of the worst
companies in existence
flying spirit airlines is a it's a even
compared to most other airlines and this
is saying something it's a
miserable experience they spirit
airlines they hate their customers
you can just tell they hate you it's one
of those things
and this is at every level in my
experience anyway
customer service if you have to call
them or you get on the flight the flight
attendants
everyone's in a bad mood they don't like
you they don't want you there
so it's a horrible service um
the the planes are cramped it's like
they're sticking you into these sardine
cans
and uh and on top of that they treat
their customers like crap as you just
saw there
if that's not enough to convince you the
thing is i would say i will happily pay
like 400
more to fly on a better airline
but all the other airlines are crap too
so or most of them anyway all right
number three derek chovin's defense
yesterday started um
homing in on the concept of camera
perspective bias
and what they're suggesting is that at
least some of the video we've seen of
chauvin
supposedly kneeling on on uh george
floyd's neck
may have been deceptive not to say they
were deceptively edited but
but just that the perspective of the
camera is misleading
so here's a pretty i think a pretty uh
pretty stunning moment
where the the defense attorney
gets the police chief to agree that um
at least for part of this time derek
chovin did not have his knee on george
floyd's neck but had his knee on george
floyd's back so let's uh let's watch
this
chief that from the perspective of miss
frazier's camera it appears that officer
chauvin's knee
is on the neck of mr floyd
yes
okay now they're changing the camera to
a different angle
because you can see they've got the
split screen
and you can see one one angle it really
looks like
derek shelvin has his knee on the neck
sorry i didn't want to
do that but you can't always trust we
should have learned this by now you
can't always trust these uh
the videos that you see of these
incidents
of course we see the videos out of
context everyone immediately jumps to
conclusion
but sometimes it's deceptive
and eventually he's going to ask the
police chief the question i think
would you agree that from the
perspective of
officer king's body camera it appears
that officer chauvin's knee was more on
mr floyd's
shoulder blade um
yes
i have no further questions so
significant moment
um right there because it's all about
again just selling the reasonable doubt
uh seeds of doubt that's that's what
defense attorney's supposed to do
he doesn't have to prove innocence he
just has to prove or demonstrate
that the prosecution has not made its
case beyond a reasonable doubt so
there's doubt
now about how long
derek shelvin had his knee on um george
floy's neck
doubt about that uh there's doubt about
how exactly
george floyd died there are conflicting
medical examinations
medical examiners saying different
things
there's doubt about whether he died of
an overdose
at a minimum there's doubt about all
these things
does all that add up to reasonable doubt
about chauvin's guilt or innocence
certainly seems to all right number four
this is from the hill it says
a new state law in utah will legally
require that biological fathers pay half
of women's pregnancy expenses
some states such as new york and
wisconsin have similar financial
provisions for pregnancies
the bill signed by governor spencer cox
a republican
was well received by utah's republican
majority legislature and will apply to
pregnancy-related medical costs
in cases where a child's paternity is
disputed the father won't need to pay
until paternity is established
fathers also will not be liable to pay
for abortions carried out without their
consent
except in cases of rape or when the
mother's life is endangered
um yeah republicans apparently are
celebrating this
i i'm i wish that i could
support a bill like this i you know in
principle
um in a in a perfect ideal world i would
support this because
yes if you're a father and you
you know it takes two to tango as they
say and um if you help to conceive a
child then
you should be responsible for that child
and that responsibility should be you
know again in an ideal
situation that responsibility would even
be
you know there would be law behind that
to enforce it
now if you're doing what you should do
this should be a non-issue
like if you get married and then you
have kids then you don't have to worry
about splitting at 50 50.
i mean i really paid for 100 of our
pregnancy related costs because i'm the
breadwinner in the family and we're
married and so it's not an issue enough
to think about it right
but these are the complications you do
have to consider if you um
you know are having kids out of wedlock
but the reason why
i can't support this is that we we don't
live we live in something quite far from
the ideal
world and in this non-ideal world there
is as was mentioned here
abortion and what that means is that the
mother
has 100 authority
to have her child executed and the
father has no say in that whatsoever
so you can't have it both ways here if
if
if we're going to legally require men to
pay 50 for uh
make them financially responsible for 50
of the pregnancy then do they also have
50
say in whether the child is going to be
executed
if they don't then i don't see how you
can put them on uh
you know i don't see how you can give
them half the tab for the pregnancy
costs
but you know either we are legally
treating the unborn child
as also the father's child or not
either the unborn child is legally also
the father's child and the father's
responsibility or not
and if you're telling me that the father
has no right
to stop the woman from having the child
executed then what you're telling me is
that
legally while the child is in the womb
it's not really the father's child and
not really the father's responsibility
that's not the way it should be that's
the way it is though
so we can't do this other stuff until we
first take care of that problem
all right number five finally news from
really important news i've been waiting
to get to this
uh news from fiu the fiu football
twitter account
and it says please welcome coach horny
to fiu as our new special teams
coordinator
coach horny i gotta say i'm really
fascinated by this career change for uh
katie hill you know she went from
congress to coaching football
big step that's it that's
i just wanted to make that joke about
coach horney that's a real guy there's a
guy his name's really coach horny i
don't know anything else about him
i just know that's his name and i know
presumably he has lived with that name
his whole life
which is unthinkable how how do you
survive middle school with an with a
name like horny
how do you do that i really think as a
you know don't you have you have a
responsibility
as a parent to like probably change your
last name i don't know how
that's probably a difficult thing to do
but you got you got to do something you
can't saddle a kid with that
it's not gonna work how do you do
anything i mean how do you ask a girl on
a date
as a teen boy with a last name like
horny
and then he becomes a coach so which
means that he's always going to be
identified
by his last name for the rest of his
life
that's tough and here i am making fun of
it like a middle schooler myself
what else am i going to do all right
let's move to reading the youtube
comments this is from caleb says hey
matt long time listener and enjoyer of
the show
um you are my favorite dw host and i
want to get on reading the comment
section and i see that flattery works
for this
it does indeed it does indeed another
comment says
tap water is really the champagne of
freedom
to be honest what tap water is the
champagne of freedom
and this comment has like five likes
don't don't like it don't encourage that
that doesn't make any sense that doesn't
mean anything
uh madeline says i'll stop drinking coke
if the rest of you do
well i already did i stopped drinking
coke um
you know years ago because i decided i
wanted to live past the age of 45.
you were just if you're drinking
especially non-diet coke
you are you might as well like three
times a day go grab a whole bag of sugar
and just
start dumping it into your mouth
so yes i already stopped drinking it so
it is i admit
easy for me to boycott coke because i
really don't drink it anyway but even so
that's what we should all do christian
says please review the new space jam
trailer i remember when you cancelled
your kids
last time over space jam lol i did see
there's a new space jam coming out with
lebron james and i did watch the trailer
speaking of incoherent it makes no sense
whatsoever it's it's really and this is
no surprise it's
i guess we could call it product
placement the movie
because i don't know what the plot is
but it appears to be it's just one long
commercial
for all of the movie studios other
products and
uh and franchises that's that and that's
also the point of every superhero movie
by the way it's really one long
commercial
for the merchandise and the action
figures it's like every superhero movie
is one long
action figure commercial that's its main
function
um let's see armando says matt you're
missing the point on the amazon
controversy controversy
workers feel forced to urinate and
defecate on bags because of the
unreasonable and unrealistic goals
set by amazon they have a horrible
system in which workers feel they have
to outperform to meet the ridiculous
goals
so i get i worked for a call center
years ago when i was a teenager where
they stopped paying you
if you went to the bathroom but you were
only paid
you had to sit there and you know you
had your head set on
and i was a telemarketer okay uh one of
the most so
you know what what the the hated dreaded
telemarketer
and you sat there um
at your computer and it would it would
automatically dial people and you just
and you'd take one call after another
if you put your headset if you paused it
and put your headset down and went to go
to the break room for a second to get
some water or go to the bathroom
you were not paid for that time every
second that you were not
in the process of making a call or
taking a call you were not paid
so i understand that but in this case
they're complaining
that drivers i don't know what's going
on at the amazon warehouses and as i
said i have no interest in defending
amazon i don't care about defending them
but the complaint or part of the
complaint was that drivers on the road
were forced to pee in bottles i still
don't understand how that could be
amazon's fault
they can't really do anything about the
scarcity of bathrooms on a highway can
they
um
let's see lauren west finally says
honestly i agree i'm 17 and yet i'm
having trouble deciding to go to college
or not
well i could tell you you know here's my
advice you're 17
[Music]
presumably you're going to i guess
you're going to well you're going to
graduate this year so uh
what i would say is don't that's
actually an easy choice
don't go to college right now i'm not
saying never go
but there's really no compelling reason
for a 17 or 18 year old to
go to college you can graduate high
school
go out and work in the in the real world
for a little bit
college will always be there there's no
downside
at all you take a couple you're not
who are you you're not racing anybody
there's this is not a race
college is always going to be there
they'll always be more than happy to
take your money if you want to give it
to them
so there's no downside and taking a
couple of years you work you earn some
money get some life experience
maybe figure out yourself a little bit
more figure out what you want to do with
your life
and then with that experience a little
bit of money under your belt
and um knowing uh having a clear picture
of your future goals
then if you want to going to college
that's my advice no downside to it
it's all upside best kind of advice now
a quick word from our friends over at
constitutioncoach.com listen i've been
telling you about these guys
um for weeks now and for very good
reason because
as conservatives right we say we love
the constitution the rule of law
and all of that but i think few of us
have taken the time that we need to
study it
and uh and fewer of us stand ready to
defend it and defend ourselves
that's what constitutioncoach.com is all
about they've got a lot of great
programs for equipping citizens to
defend liberty and
live out the constitution i've
experienced this myself with their
constitutional defense course
which is uh it's it's all about the
intellectual
giving you the intellectual ammunition
that you need learning about the
constitution learning about our history
but also
you're also getting that physical
training at the premier firearms
training facility in the nation
all in the same course trust me you're
not going to regret doing something like
this
you'll be very thankful that you did i
know that i am you get to join hundreds
of other patriots from across the nation
for a time of learning training and
fellowship
with like-minded people whether you've
shot guns your whole life or if you've
never touched one doesn't matter i'm
telling you these people
they took me to an entirely new skill
level and they could do the same with
you okay if they could do it with me
they can do with you i guarantee you
don't just get a gun learn how to carry
it with confidence
go to to go to constitutioncoach.com
and listen uh rick in the constitution
coach team they have another class on
april 25th
but it's filling up is your last chance
to sign up okay
so you got to go to
constitutioncoach.com don't put it off
if you put it off today is the day to do
it
and you can watch my video there as well
to find out more about how you can be a
part of this one-of-a-kind training go
there now sign up constitutioncoach.com
and as we return from eastern passover
it's important to reflect you know on
the impact that these holidays have on
our faith and the impact that
judeo-christian values have on our
culture
more and more the left wants to erase
these values and replace them with their
own pseudo
morality that's why we've launched a
brand new talk show with candace owens
one of the fiercest protectors of
conservative values
at free speech that there is you can go
behind the headlines go behind the
twitter fights to see candace as herself
and you can watch her host lively
discussion panels
and exclusive interviews with an always
exciting round of guests
including myself i'd say i was pretty
exciting
and in fact i was on her show last week
let's play a
quick clip of that what that happens
when these kids who can't show up on
time who aren't actually passing on the
basis of what they know when they get
out into the real world i'm opening that
up for any of you guys
i'll say i i always thought that they'll
get out into the real world
and they're going to be introduced to
reality and they're going to have to
adjust to it
and that's what we all said all
conservatives said that all these
snowflakes are gonna get out into
the real world but then we forgot that
they that they they get to make the real
world i mean they're the ones taking
over
and so they have reshaped reality in
their image and so fortunately
uh they're not really getting the wake
up the rest of us are getting the wake
we'll call
brilliant brilliant point and uh great
jacket on that guy also candace is great
too
candace is um also the first daily wire
show to appear in front of a live studio
audience
an element that's rarely been seen in
conservative media and you're getting
all of that it's just
it's a great show overall the show
streams on fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8
pm central at dailywire.com but you can
get the audio podcast candace on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcast
so go there now get the uh get the
podcast and remember to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
now let's get to our daily cancellation
today we're going to cancel everybody
involved with this story in usa today
written by rasha ali
it's titled quote the pandemic forced us
to stop hugging and shaking hands
that's not necessarily a bad thing the
article goes on to quote a number of
supposed experts including dr fauci who
argues that we as a society
should never go back to what were once
uh normal universal ways of greeting
each other
fauci is quoted as saying that we should
never shake hands again
because shaking hands is quote really
one of the major ways that you transmit
a respiratory illness
that's what he's saying other experts
including a quote unquote experts
including a psychotherapist and a health
educator in san francisco
argue that shaking hands and hugging may
sometimes be a violation of a person's
autonomy
especially when children are urged to
participate in that custom
and so maybe that's why we should never
go back to that again from the article
it says
it's a common tale an adult relative
comes over and a parent tells a child to
greet that person with a hug or a kiss
but his physical touch vanished during
the pandemic the pressure put on kids to
physically greet each other
greet people waned and experts say it's
a practice we should stick with
after the pandemic we want our kids to
trust their intuition especially when it
relates to body autonomy
we also want kids to have a sense of
agency when it comes to their intuition
and their bodies
which is an important part of their
emerging sexuality
according to health educator shafia zulu
now okay it is of course enormously
creepy to think of a child giving their
visiting grandmother
or aunt a kiss as something at all
related to their emerging sexuality
as shafia's illume seems to it's also
insane to relate any of this to bodily
autonomy or to make an issue out of any
of it at all
and i say this as someone who quite
jealously
guards my own personal space and i have
no interest in hugging anyone outside of
my immediate family
even so i don't see the pandemic related
changes as an improvement
and i certainly wouldn't want to embrace
them as permanent solutions
now to make matters worse the article
suggests
a number of alternative greetings that
we're all invited to adopt moving
forward
um and so here are the the uh they have
a little handy chart and a diagram
showing what this would all look like
so first they have the hand wave you
know
and there's nothing wrong with a hand
wave generally but it's it's awkward to
stand three feet from someone
face to face and wave at them which is
what you see people doing now
you're just like standing that's what my
one-year-old daughter does
she'll go up to someone right in their
face and start waving like this
and that's fine for a one-year-old for
adults it looks ridiculous you're both
standing there like morons
three feet from each other waving
another suggested alternative is to put
your hand across your chest
like this which looks like a greeting
that you might see on star trek or
something
and then of course the elbow bump they
suggest where two grown adults awkwardly
touch elbows
which makes them look i don't know
deformed
or maybe it looks like they're about to
go into some kind of secret handshake
that they've devised but they both
forget the rest of the moves so they
just
stop right there whatever the case it's
stupid
and if you come up to me sticking out
your elbow and hoping that i touch it
don't be surprised if if my elbow misses
your elbow and accidentally jabs you
directly in the nose accidents happen
i mean you know you never know finally
the chart here suggests as another
option and this
apparently is not a joke it suggests
a foot shake okay now with a foot
shake i haven't seen anyone thank god
actually doing this but this is what usa
today is suggesting with a foot shake
two people walk up to each other and
while standing they look into each
other's eyes and begin to play a game of
one-legged ftse
yes because this will be way less
awkward and sexual than a handshake
somehow
i mean if you're worried about telling
your child to go give uncle george a hug
how much worse would it sound to say
johnny your uncle's here come play
footsie with him flip pla
play footsie with your uncle don't be
rude
this is why i'm happy to stick with
shaking hands and hugging
you know not only is it possible for
grown adults to engage in those
activities without looking like awkward
nerds or demented freaks which is more
than i can say for the alternatives
but it also makes social interaction
smoother
precisely because there are fewer
options
everyone understands that when you're
greeting someone it's either a handshake
or a hug
depending on your relationship to that
person now sometimes there's the
awkwardness of
you know you go for the handshake when
the other person goes for a hug
or even worse if you go for a hug and
the other person goes for a handshake
kind of letting you know where your
relationship stands
but this awkwardness was minimized by
the fact that there were only the two
options
so it's got to be one or the other if
you go for one and it's not then that
then you know you
it's the other pretty simple
if we get rid of those options and we
leave it up to each individual to devise
his own unique form of greeting
we're just going to be left not knowing
what to do
and this is the case with so much in
society because when we get rid of all
these
all these you know one at a time all
these different social conventions out
the window
and allegedly to free people up to you
know be how they want
all that means is that nobody knows how
to interact with each other
and now you get rid of handshakes and
hugs you know you might go for the wave
while they go for the elbow bump and
then you transition to the foot
shake the other person tries the hand
across the chest
all you want to do is say hi to the
person and now the two of you are doing
the hokey pokey
none of this is necessary we had a fine
system
before it was working fine there is no
reason to abandon it
you got to get over your own
compunctions your own germaphobia time
to get past that
get back to normal that's what we got to
do
and anyone with uh who who wants to get
rid of the handshake
is canceled and especially anyone who
wants to replace the handshake with a
foot shake
or elbow touching or any other
inappropriate activity like that
is also certainly canceled and we'll
leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. dr fauci
predicts no federal vaccine mandate
blm threatens to burn down more stuff
and the confused assistant secretary of
health endorses pumping little kids full
of cross-sex hormones check it out
the michael knowles show